over the last six months my team and I
been checking out your best love
restaurants from thousands of
nominations tonight the competition
continues with another of your top
culinary favorites Chinese techniques
and flavor combinations that you won't
find in any other cuisines there's a
Chinese restaurant on nearly every High
Street and there's an incredible range
from small family-run outfits the
mission star fine-dining please cut the
noodles please thank you we tend to
think of Chinese food has been all about
chow mein and special fired rice but
great Chinese restaurants serve food
that's as sophisticated and complex as
anything you'll find in a posh French
restaurant I've chosen two fantastic
restaurants to battle it out for a place
in the semi-finals tonight from Mayfair
in London it's the crazy canary genius
of Kai
No my style of cooking is the new modern
Chinese as a chef we need to perform on
our heart versus the best of the
northwest Blackburn's you and you a
brilliant family-run restaurant earliest
memory of food was just cooking with my
father he said oh you can't reach the
cook is so standing on these four cases
to live yourself oh I can only choose
one Chinese restaurant to go through the
semi-finals so they must prove to me
beyond all doubt that they are the most
worthy contender I'm going to subject
both restaurants to three challenging
tests starting with a country of 30
guests all arriving and ordering at the
same time every restaurants worst
nightmare
first they'll sachet into Mayfair to
sample the avant-garde the lights on
offer mr. stark I where is he
chef you look like you just don't have a
Chinese boy band look at that hair
incredible that I know you are a
superstar pies kitchen is led by Alex
the demanding head chef
he's a perfectionist who runs his
kitchen with a rod of iron to ensure his
sophisticated dishes are spot-on every
time I'm Batman
Alex hodie skills in some of Asia's top
five-star hotels before being poked by
tines ambitious owner Bernard the
intention was to change people's
perceptions about Chinese restaurants
they're trying to reinvent Chinese
cuisine and they put a 21st century
twist on it
amongst Thais bold and unusual dishes is
a unique liquid version of a lamb shank
does not look like a lamb shank in there
so is it supposed to be like a lamb
shank soup or yes right yes it's it's
one of those dishes which catches people
are by surprise so a lot of people
absolutely love it and some people don't
like it I just never had a lunch at that
before no no absolutely not and if you
ever sell that today obviously on the
menu make sure the customers understand
what it is before yes I don't want to
disappoint it it tastes delicious
she's a really strange way of executing
it I love these guys they are very very
creative and this food is out there and
I just hope that my diners get it and
love the experience
ty will need to be on top of the game to
survive my ultimate pressure test
two hours two courses yeah I'm gonna be
over everything I'll be in the kitchen
I'll be the dining room and I'll be
watching and listening to everything so
make sure that you give my diners and
experience never to forget normally
bookings are staggered to take the
pressure off the kitchen but not tonight
my 30 diners will push Kai to the edge
and give them a chance to shine on
Alex's ultra-modern menu tonight is a
choice of three starters wasabi pawns
with mango and basil seeds steamed
scholars with ginger and spring onions
and Kai's unusual take on a lamb starter
with such dishes my guess we'll need a
clear explanation when the order the
flavor of lamb shank but it actually
comes as a soup hit the kitchen and it
sounds like a champ alex is launching a
full-scale military assault hang on
don't go back to that well your sonic
Lamptey not young teen yeah my regenexx
yeah okay and what's the paper for table
5 for a starter
dancing the Paleo dancing that jeopardy
a newer friend I've got a headache
dancing that young teen got my what is
that researching whatever you sensing no
obvious are the order I need a Colleen
it just means into service and it's
clear that course isn't going down well
with my diners when we're done is just
complain about the lunch change goopy
soupy and normally expected settling
exactly what I predicted liquid lamb
shank may be a step too far for my guess
so I hope Alex sees amazingly
sophisticated main courses are going to
impress
he's workings ass off to make the soy
and honey marinated lamb spiced with
chilies and an extravagant lobster dish
scented with crisp curry leaves and
cooked with lemon chili and schlotz now
front of house is getting in there
mother nothing seems to be coming out
together we can't keep a table hanging
for seven minutes without anything else
arriving on a day like today that's what
I'm trying to say okay okay thank you
call the waiter may cause severe thirst
artists John send a starter and then ten
seconds late to send their main course
can you so my question originally was
who called away the main courses is it
always this crazy
there's a man busier the very childhood
service yeah one chance is fine with 15
- at the same time it's such a mess that
one diners dish the lamp have been
missed altogether I'm hoping it's gonna
arrive recently soon because I'm very
very hungry okay for a Michelin star
restaurant this is unforgivable
even worse Bernard the owner is busy
serving up excuses for free staffs
cock-ups normally a meal here everything
is in the middle of the table so
everybody's sharing which is unusually
today we've had to serve everything
individually
why are you doing that their share of
startups five but the or domain cause I
think that customer deserves it the fact
they took water down incorrectly from
the customers fault you know I have so
we should be telling them that I'd
rather you just sort of hand in the
earth deal with it and move on okay my
apologies once the food arrives
most of my diners are blown away by
Alex's amazing dishes
it is fantastic the the the Lambs tender
just wonderful
Bob stir and it was absolutely fantastic
I've never had lobster that's been fried
before and it was really nice contrast
as well as having the strawberries and
the grapes and their lobster was lovely
very subtle flavors of garlic actually
but yeah amazing end of service and time
to tell Kai what I thought the customers
are did get the food on time love the
food it's quirky and it's very striking
when it hits all those notes but we have
to remember that when customers come in
for the first time you've got to hold
their hand every step of the way that's
where we've got to work on yeah just got
to keep working keep working make it a
little bit better every single
absolutable but I know you can go
further because you've done it with the
food and you can do it with the service
as well hit all those notes there put
them together bang you have an amazing
restaurant I'm scouring the country in a
quest to find my very best restaurant my
coach load of 30 diners is about to hit
the second Chinese restaurant battling
for a place in the semi-finals of my
nationwide competition
it's family-run you are new in Blackburn
so many of you nominated them you and
you have to go into my top two Chinese
[Music]
it's got that that energy that vibe and
this family run run with great passion
you can feel that because they care
about every little detail family is the
most important power this restaurant
I think person like it makes this
restaurant what it is you know it that's
the heart and soul of the restaurant
it's not just a livelihood it's more
than that it's a definite passion that
Charlie started out with a chippy over
30 years ago before opening his first
restaurant in 1989 you see survived it's
still flames in it you know it's life
he's quicker than me there's a saying
they're older the ginger the hoary gasps
now all three of these children work in
the business the worker work what makes
it special and stand out is that
Charlie's head chef son Victor sorts the
very best local ingredients
but scholars a massive arrived at this
morning they're beautiful thank you you
and you will have just two hours to
serve all 30 of my diners a perfect meal
I'm excited already tonight's dishes
include hand dive salt and pepper olives
fill it state with hoisin and chili bean
sauce and a luxurious stir-fried Dover
sole
absolute vicious it's completely that's
for me what I dish needs is just a touch
more seasoning yeah okay
my diners look excited by what's on
offer but I wish the front of house team
would make a point of telling them how
fantastic the raw ingredients are that
song have the scallops with asparagus
and mushrooms for all they know the
scholars could have come from the
supermarket
it's Victor and Charlie's chance to show
me they can handle this challenge to the
target once that turbo wok is fired up
dish you start flying out the door
last week it's just over two minutes
from the first order coming in for food
to leave the kitchen
Victor's brother and sister are joined
in front of house by at least eight
other waiting staff who seemed to do a
lot of waiting seems to be a lot of
people just milling about I'm not really
paying these checks to the table
Blackburn's next top model it's complete
overkill and half the time they don't
even know where to put themselves my
main concern is the way the kitchen is
working Victor the head chef picks the
ingredients
another chef add the sauce then it's
that Charlie who does all the cooking
[ __ ] Israelis they're coming every [ __ ]
just cooking cooking cooking I know it
come here prayer no-man's anyone doing
alone
thank you feel guilty that's the way why
should the only one doing any work could
you - he's control control busy a
control freak
please let go a little thing you still
think he's gonna do one day a week at
ninety seriously seriously yeah orders
have already backed up by the time head
chef Victor steps in to help with the
cookie
there's something quite unique about
seeing to follow some of us so together
you know
[Music]
what hope dishes are now getting out
there's a problem yeah I'll sort it for
your no prob thinking don't taste
anything we're square norm for the way
they work as the Chinese kitchen but the
young guys now start to cook and also
Victor skip as well now say got same
dish we got by three different
individuals so that's how things started
coming consistent I can't believe that
Charlie and Victor are letting down
their delicious and unique ingredients
through lack of seasoning once I really
enjoyed the starts everyone L know we're
a little bit bland so just make sure if
someone's gonna cook it they're gonna
taste it as well if it needs a touch
more salt okay Charlie thank you it's
not just the scallops they're also under
seasoning their most expensive dish
three plates of a 30-pound ahead Dover
sole have you sent back give me a favor
give me another Dover sole dog solid
cylinder season
there definitely is more so it's a hardy
family
I've been a service I mentioned that
service oh yeah fish tastes delicious
but it's underseasoned and three times
tonight you guys come back bland
you've got to do justice Charlie's
happened to me do the soul it's an
expensive dish to get wrong so many
times
[Music]
when they hit their stride you and use
food is extraordinary now that you
family need to hear what I thought up
tonight's service this is a first for me
I've never come across a Chinese
restaurant that has such unique
ingredients and so if you are going to
hell him back to sauces ingredients
shout about it I could cry on the back
of the Dover sole because I said to you
when you cooked it for me earlier it
needed more seasoning and it came back
three times tonight taste it do it just
this yeah you're the chef and your
father's a sous chef and tonight it
looked like you were the apprentice and
your father was the chef and grabbed the
reins and let him sit behind you well
done thank you I slowed down if they
homed in on those small little details
with the final seasoning across those
dishes and you've got something pretty
phenomenal
[Music]
can i and you and you have cooked their
hearts out but both have their failings
and things are about to get a whole lot
tougher the coast trip really showed me
what these Chinese competitors are made
of and now I've called both of them to a
meeting with me to find out how their
restaurant when when I'm not breathing
down their necks I've been spying on
them and they have no idea if you want
to know how in restaurant treats an
ordinary customer on an ordinary day
send in a secret diner that's exactly
what I do they should get amazing food
and excellent service nothing less is
good enough
sarah Durden robertson has worked with
me and other top chefs to create and
perfect thousands of dishes true critic
Simon Davis is one of the best in the
business and has judged food and service
have thousands of restaurants I'm
allergic to those I can't eat sultanas
it's one thing serving easy to please
customers but how old my competitors
perform when my undercover diners are
deliberately difficult and demanding
first up is cayenne Mayfair in their
first Test my customers didn't get a
proper steer on Alex's ambitious menu
has owner Bernard improve things since
my last visit that was a big test
unknown to all of you you've been tested
twice after I left KY I sent in my
secret diner and I need you to watch
this
[Music]
yes one o'clock yeah yes the starters
are warded rossabi horse and soft-shell
crab but I'm going to change my order
once I've seen that he's put it through
and I'm gonna order the lamb shank
that's right can I change my order that
started from I'd like their lamb shank
yes thank you okay hi sorry I asked to
swap for a lamb shank
well yeah but what's the additional
order yeah yeah sorry thank you
so the kitchens ended up cooking an
extra dish because the way to never said
that it was an exchange that's why he
didn't come and ask it seems to be a bit
of a lack of communication between some
of the front past our own kitchen what
goes through your mind when you see that
there Bernard
I think palate reason why we made a
mistake is because it's not unusual for
somebody to have three starters between
two people oh my goodness and a martini
glass that's not what I was expecting
Wow thank you did I read the money right
that bears no resemblance to the dish
that I was reading about I'm sorry I
just I can't believe it that's what I
ordered
very weird go ahead of the soft-shell
crab instead thank you it wasn't clear
from the menu at all that that's what
that dish is like why are we serving
lamb shank
in a martini glass there's hot it just
seemed so strange as such a bizarre
thing to do it's a fair fancy stuff that
fantasy starter Jesus
the issue we have for the chaste rice
wine flaming is that very often the
flames are quite hard to see no one can
see the [ __ ] plane because it doesn't
give off a lot of flame it's a little
bit of fun it's a bit of showmanship I
don't see anything wrong with that
there's a consistent strand through here
that you're trying to be clever with the
martini glass the lamb shank and now
you're fond buying something that it's
got nothing to do with flavor don't
damage what you got by trying to be too
clever
[Music]
have been delicious
that's really kind thank you that
somebody who clean fries and stuff on
the service they feel they ought to food
they want to hit the table it has to be
perfect or they're not happy including
after okay brilliantly handle all the
ends offering the whole thing on the
house I think the the emotion I feel
right now is more determination than
disappointment you've got to get your
head down and make things better I hope
we can now really tonight to fantastic
restaurants are battling it out to
become my best Chinese and win it place
in the semi-finals of my nationwide
restaurant competition time for you and
you to find out how they measured up
when I sent in my secret-spy unlearned
all four of you you've actually been
tested twice I sent in my secret diner
and this is what you saw I told the you
family to focus on detail and to
properly seasoned the stunning
ingredients they sauce and I want to see
them use the waiting start wisely so
they're not just hanging around
I got table David Duncan for two people
at eight o'clock
[Music]
would have put tripping off for the
drink by now having been there for five
my know they're busy but it's quite a
lot of smoke as well because he's
managing the place it all feels a bit
frantic how many would like to have a
drink that you can get rather like for
some drinks to call over the waitress to
get a drink
given to my right it's for waiters and
waitresses they've all got their backs
to us for that busy it's a busy night
ten minutes of a drink is that all they
wait 10-15 minutes no it's not well that
was an enum Friday night because one of
the kitchen hands was I'll fail yeah so
I have to go in and the hell these guys
that's not I disappeared for so long
what you need to do is pay money for
better staff and less of them that are
more reliable are starters what they
should be doing now is coming up to us
and just having a quiet word you know
what that would completely dilute the
situation completely ignored completely
ignored it becomes an insult where they
become offended like you said defuse it
that's okay okay thank you miss Davis
always sugar snap peas and carrot soups
actually rather rather bland
and the fish itself
it's pretty nondescript either just this
Dover so doesn't be tasted much and it's
been much more seasonal when you've got
customers that are sat waiting over half
an hour of food it's got to be perfect
and I was dealt with quite well so I
understand there's clappy going are to
change the dish
I still don't like it I'm afraid
I'm so sorry Oliver
ten out of ten for dealing with a very
very tricky the story brilliantly
handled and he's fussy beautifully done
I'm really really really really like
that this probably samosa it's worth the
truth alone I've never heard such an
amazing compliment to Chinese desserts
fantastic really good the dining
experience under start
I've now reached a crescendo where I
think is one of them
Chinese restaurant [ __ ] too many
years or a strong finish and he left on
a high got this far now we just really
want to I'm ready to explode I'm ready
to win this competition I'm gonna take
this and hope get to the end of this
competition you know we're two best
Chinese restaurants have one final
chance to really deliver in my
competition I'm taking them out of their
comfort zones and into the kitchen of my
own michelin-starred restaurant I've
asked each chef to create one amazing
dish for 20 guests the test here today
is about quality and consistency every
single plate they produce must be
perfect
their performance will win one of them
our place in the semi-finals the other
will be eliminated from the competition
the pressure will either make or break
them
seen the name of the menu accordance
three-star Michelin restaurant want to
win this will cook aha
oh we had make they were definitely try
our best to mix it the diner happy is
this is an amazing battle about to take
place now because we've got two
completely contrasting restaurants on
what the quality to stand out create
something magical the sad news is
there's only one of you go through to
the semi-final make sure it's you good
luck to both you thank you
they must create their dish using the
finest quality beef as their main
ingredients and I'm expecting great
things from both teams it's not just me
they have to impress some highly
distinguished guests will also judge
both restaurants dishes including data
Zhang a world authority on Chinese
cuisine and respected businesswoman
mason lie OBE I've also invited each
restaurants front-of-house team for the
chef's there is nowhere to hide I'm
expecting culinary perfection
okay I'll order four covers Table six
Kai Paul beef and ginger okay
yes chef will be great yeah chef thank
you is if I share like that is that will
that will that make getting easier no
tell me know is it who is it is it yeah
no just in case at Kai alex is a gifted
and passionate mastermind elevating
modern Chinese food to new heights Alex
and wing his sous chef hoped in charm I
guess with the creation you'd never find
on a high street Chinese menu then they
can be sirloin with ginger and spring
onion pesto so with broccolini bamboo
stalks and pumpkin is accompanied by
spiced rice and a soy reduction pencil
yep ken are kind of the regular any
finishing that I wanna run and hop in it
it's so nice to see my kitchen and how
nice is that we've been here five
minutes you haven't shouted very good
thank you thanks an order you and you to
give us way Table 3 please - stunning
Wagyu beef - yeah yeah is that thanks
charlie in contrast you and you is going
for a more classic dish wok seared Kobe
beef with sweet soy sauce lime garlic
and ginger Kobe beef is an amazingly
tender cut of meat but the magic in this
dish lies with the flavoring
that's what we've always done that so
keeping things simple using fresh really
good ingredients you know I've been
waiting to say a victor the head chef
can live up to the title and take
control from his father tasting today
every [ __ ] thing you call that plate
I will see you taste I need to see you
taste yeah I'm not on your shoulders
right now and that standard has been met
by you today yeah sure
Victor has the pressure of the
competition and the desire to impress
his dad resting on his shoulders he
needs to stay calm and in control but
for my first table of four Victor dishes
up just one plate that's the first beef
yes
don't just mission Shumacher sorry
missing one just miss him three more on
there yeah so is that three in there
yeah how long's that gonna take
we'll make the finisher how long's
you're gonna take four minutes check
four minutes well it's gonna be [ __ ]
wife four minutes what do you want me to
do serve that are you going to do for
fresh portions again halo chose Hina
serve that
[Music]
come on Victor I know you can do better
than this I can't just serve one portion
wasn't read to do I take you back
I can't just serve one two minutes and
out this one off the shipping service
please go with her please Jenna there's
only rice is that the all right put me
in focus a one-pound bears all up come
on guys listen just stop come here two
seconds
what the [ __ ] are you doing what is that
and if this is your moment
Jenna standards so get that back in
there split it between four plates come
on guys I know you can do better than
this but if you talk to each other the
rice comes at the same time I say one
[ __ ] L guys that's done by you and
you when we completely disorientated no
teamwork and their fathers son we've got
to say today do it like two strangers in
the kitchen come here two seconds you
this is not a [ __ ] rehearsal you
understand it sure I can't just send
that one Porsche owners house I've got
dining room full of guests out there
listen to me and more importantly slow
down and come to the hot plate together
come on this one
on the other side of the kitchen alex is
also feeling the pressure
time to forces away alex true please
stand mad at me look at me look at me
yeah Shelbys that's it thank you
laughter nice to be yes yeah thank you
okay now to take our place Alex isn't
communicating with me or a sous-chef
wing [ __ ] you now come on guys and this
complex dish knees perfect coordination
Alex look at me if we get a little bit
organized yeah so the beef doesn't hang
around too long on hot plate yeah it's
got a go yes I can't sit here too long
don't work together a little bit more
yeah chef yeah so you putting it on I
was taking about four or five minutes
but it's got to go we can't keep it back
too long yeah otherwise gonna be cold
Brady oh God service please
Alexes food looks amazing but he seems
to be struggling to cope in my kitchen
without his large team your chicken
start boiling over on the hot plate
please okay fine I'll be letting go
let's go take the [ __ ] paint I want
to a shelf there as well stop you go you
let's go go go go yeah boo that's nice
I'll be done yes
yep Joe please let's go Table two
where's the sauce
good thank you sauce pour the left-hand
side Alex I want all the pot sometimes
my kitchen here in 50 I've never had an
accident and today I'm not going to have
one yeah let's go
Jesus Christ very nice Palace peaceful
service please don't sever one please
yep thank you
[Music]
I'm still a bit nervous seeing this now
a lot better okay big yeah forward
you'll be four wait table one yeah all
at the same time to rise to vegetables
and to summon a new breed yes yes thank
you
come on I look at me always just take a
grip solid hold those reins yeah and get
this thing back on track yes and make
sure every plate is absolutely perfect
please yo your mother said out there you
know that don't you yeah okay for bit
please stop by let's go please
let's go I hope you learn thank you
thank you excellent Gordon just sell the
nerves and then no one need to do you
and you have come back strong and
they've got that focus going on now
[Music]
plate after place of Victor's
mouth-watering beef is finally been
served
[Music]
look Sid wakey
[Music]
I feed this delicious very tender what
do you think I'm really proud of my dad
and my brother just getting this far and
what they've cooked today's being
amazing in a kitchen they're not so used
to as well our kids are definitely done
as proud yes service is over and it's
time to discover what my distinguished
guests think about these two
extraordinary dishes starting with
Victor's wonderful
we were so tender and special it worked
very well you have more authentic
flavors not only the presentation but
the flavors it's much better as well
I think it was the better dish made me
because of the tenderness of the beef
the accompanying dishes particularly the
rice that the rice was outstanding my
diners comments are testament to the
incredible standards of both Kai and you
and use food but this competition is
about more than just one dish both these
fantastic Chinese restaurants have had
their ups and downs throughout this hate
but now it's time for me to choose
between them meaning today is very
important for me because I really want
to be a proud to my family as a one of
I thought my turn each other in London
but if I'd be Kaiser the only woman
there such a fantastic restaurant and
their dish is unbelievable you know so
we can only see you know we'd be image
it would be unbelievable
only one of them can go through to the
semi-finals I've got to make a very
difficult choice my two top Chinese
chefs Alex and Victor have finished the
service of their lives and my three
Michelin star restaurant
they've both proved themselves
exceptional competitors but one team has
to go it's time to taste this incredible
food cooked here today starting with a
dish created by Alex from kind and
Mayfair sauce the beef marinated 24
hours by swine
beats delicious sauce is very very
strong
pumpkins very crunchy bamboo shoot
country slightly acidic but delicious
you knew Wagyu beef
hmm it just melts in your mouth it's
delicious I mean it's really delicious
my god it's got a texture of foie gras
and needs the greens with it
it's very rich but it's incredibly
moreish and you feel like it's done with
a level of authenticity they both hold
an amazing flavor who has the edge of
this one both these teams have cooked
their hearts out but there can only be
one winner
[Music]
okay I brought you here today for one
reason and one reason only to do
something extraordinary to do something
that was out of your comfort zone and
into a completely different league KY
the dish you looked at it was like it
come out of a Gucci handbag it was all
precise and just beautifully done
the beef phenomenal love the marinade
intelligent smart and it had that kind
of wow
criticizing the dish
I would have cooked the pumpkin for
another two minutes is there we crunchy
inside
you knew the Wagyu absolutely beautiful
because you you played To Your Strengths
what would I change it was simple today
I didn't think you'd go simple I thought
you'd go a little bit more a little bit
more daring
but this competition is not gonna be won
or lost on one dish alone I'm looking
for the best restaurant great food great
service great atmosphere friendly
approach and something that you want to
go back to that restaurant for that
phenomenal experience
[Music]
the restaurant that's going through to
the semi-final based on everything
I've seen taste it and being part of is
[Music]
Junior
continue those fireworks yeah you
deserve to be out there love the
fireworks love it love it love it
good job there one amazing restaurant
yet look after
because I'm absolute gutted that we're
not getting through the answer wasn't
the answer we would have liked to hear
but we have to move on and keep going
with what we do every single day
well done really well done I said you
had a lot of weigh on your shoulders
today and you pulled it off
I was just based on that dish is based
on the whole experience really well done
you should be incredibly proud yeah a
bloody good job get really well done
well done well done well done
I'm very happy it feels amazing I can't
wait anymore that's just good believe
[Music]
we're very powerful Universal yeah I'm
all Robbie's yeah no you're into a good
job being a good teacher
yeah it's a good job
[Music]
that's a lot maybe good
[Music]
through a jungle
[Music]
pretty sorry to say goodbye to Kai and
that chefs a bit of a mad genius however
you and you great restaurant
what an amazing family and they're the
consistent and United